let me begin
by once again acknowledging the bravery
and the sacrifice that
our military makes every single day and
the loss of those americans and marines
and sailor and army personnel
is tragic as i said yesterday and
prime minister i've talked about it
slightly it's he's a
military man gone to war lost a friend
you know losing
a son a daughter a husband a wife
is uh
like being sucked into a big black hole
in your chest you don't think there's
any way out
i wonder what's happening so my heart
goes out our hearts go out to all those
who we've lost but look
the mission there
being performed is dangerous
and is
now
it's come with a significant loss of
american personnel
and uh but it's a worthy mission because
they continue to evacuate
uh folks out of that region out of the
airport evacuated more than 12 000
additional people out of
the airport in the last
24 hours
i met with my commanders this morning
first thing in the morning got a
detailed briefing
about yesterday's attacks and the
measure they're taking to protect our
forces and complete the mission
and we will complete the mission